elles sont plongées au cœur de la
recherche et du développement du Groupe
Renault 22 élèves du lycée Villaroy de
Guyancourt ont visité le Technocentre le
site d'ingénierie du constructeur
automobile au losange c'est lycéenne ont
pu découvrir les activités du service en
charge de tester les matériaux qui
composent les véhicules un premier
atelier qui montre comment nous faisons
des validations de matériaux plastiques
ou de tissus par rapport à du
vieillissement intérieur et extérieur du
vieillissement UV le deuxième atelier
est un atelier plus accès sur le choix
des matériaux mais d'un point de vue
sensoriel pour augmenter le plaisir du
toucher des matériaux intérieurs
habitacle pour nos clients cette visite
une initiative de Sandrine Lamarque
professeur de physique-chimie de
l'établissement et les ateliers
s'inscrivent pleinement dans la
pédagogie de ces élèves qui suivent une
filière scientifique ce qui m'a le plus
plus je dirais